шановні українці я пам'ятаю як під час
виборчої кампанії 19-го року партія
слуга народу ідуча на вибори дуже
ретельно розповідала що пустого залу в
парламенті бути не може апріорі що тут
має бути завжди повний зал і всі питання
мають
голосуватися я доповідаю І зараз якщо
оператори покажуть не покриваючи в залі
наразі присутні 39 народних
депутатів з 4
якщо не помиляюся станом на даний момент
в залі присутній аж один керівник
фракції з восьми і це опозиція це не
монобільшість в залі присутні чотири
керівника комітетів
тільки Таким чином з
27 просто колеги якщо ви щось говорите
під час виборів то виконуйте свої
обіцянки а не бршіть людям шановні
громадяни України Мені прикро що вам
доводиться зараз спостерігати це
абсолютну маніпуляцію і фарс у цьому
залі очевидно що навіть представляти
Постанову і суть її немає перед ким тому
що немає тих хто може проголосувати за
її підтримання Хоча я вважаю що ця цей
проект закону який був проголосований в
залі він більше подібний на докторську
справа аніж на законопроект який реально
буде якимось чином послуговуватися в
доско
лення юридичної процедури во
правочинної процедури тут в нас у
Верховній Раді України але я хочу
скористатися цією можливістю і сказати
про інше хочу сказати про те що
парламент принижується в дуже різні
способи і парламент сьогодні змушений
виконувати вказівку банкової щодо
невипуску парламентарів навіть у робочі
відрядження за кордон ми як парламентарі
які
вміємо якісно Виконувати свою роботу на
користь держави України які вміємо
переконувати наших партнерів у
необхідності подальшої підтримки Україні
змушені відмовлятися від участі у
серйозних міжнародних заходах через те
що якісь виродки з монобільшості
вирішили з'їздити чи то в Болгарію чи то
на Мальдіви чи то в Тайланд і тому
сьогодні керівництво Верховної Ради
України вирішило що воно є тим законом
який може
забороняти Вибачте в незаконний спосіб
виїзд на роботу для захисту національних
інтересів України депутатів за кордон це
велика ганьба І це ще
одна крапля яка добиває залишки
парламентаризму в Україні
Дякую Шановні колеги ну з великою
повагою до вас до виступаючих але
Скажіть будь ласка ну цинічно зараз
розказуєте про свою так звану помилку
про збільшення кількості членів
рахункової палати з дети до до 13 а
насправді ви тоді сповідували дуже
корисливий момент ціль яку тоді ставили
перед собою розмити голоси які міг
набрати той не невигідний для вас голова
рахункової палати створити для нього
умови за яких ви би впливали на на
роботу цього ога ну я не розумію ви
говорите про незалежність органу Да ви
зараз все робите для того щоби ще одна
інституція стала залежна виключно від
вас Ну просто вже Сил немає терпіти цю
цинічну брехню яку весь час ви тут
говорите з цієї трибуни Я погоджуюсь
лише з тим що висновки рахункової палати
навіть ви не читаєте Я читаю кожний звіт
пишу про себе по кожному розділу дописи
звертаюсь до до них за поясненнями що
вони мали на увазі жоден правоохоронний
орган ніяк не відреагував на кількість
величезну кількість зауважень які вони
дають в своїх звітах тому що ви їм не
даєте команду цих правоохоронним органам
Як тільки ви дасте фаз то по звіту цігої
рахункової палати всі понесуть
відповідальність Перестаньте обманювати
Вже дістало розвалили буквально всі
інституції Антимонопольний комітет Фонд
держмайна добрались до рахункової палати
стидо Дякую друзі Я звертаю вашу увагу
Ну чесно кажучи мені соромно перед тими
громадянами України які може за вночі
побачать це тут в залі знаходиться 20-30
депутатів що це було незрозуміло нащо
так ганьбити парламент не розумію але
зараз хочу сказати про інше ми
розглядаємо блокуючу Постанову яку я
зареєстрував 24 серпня А блокуючи
Постанову пана цабаля яка заблокувала
доплати в 30 000 грн всім ДСНС поліція
тиловики Нацгвардія ДПСУ дсст всім
військовослужбовцям яка була
зареєстрована ще в квітні цього року вже
скоро півроку ми її не розглядаємо
фактично створений просто механізм як
можна заблокувати і знищити будь-який
прийнятий закон і ще Ну вдвічі втричі
ганебно що це стосується наших
захисників тридцятку яку обіцяли
президент Зеленський сказав публічно
тридцятка буде до кінця війни Війна не
закінчилася тридцятка закінчилася
Верховна Рада проголосувала І що І
нічого І так цей закон заблокований люди
гроші не отримують більше того за
останні декілька місяців наш закон який
ми прийняли який вступив в силу 30
червня який передбачає доплати
строковикам курсантам обмежено придатним
після поранення виведеним позаштат
інструкторам
До сих пір жоден з них не отримав жодної
копійки жодної тому що наш Уряд нічого
не зробив Ну чим зайняти наш Уряд Я не
знаю але до сих пір тривають
бюрократичні процедури більше того
бойові доплати Нацгвардії ДПСУ за
червень і липень місяць і СБУ теж не
отримані десятки тисяч людей які
захищають нас кожен день ми витерли об
них ноги Та ми дотискаємо ми обов'язково
доб'ємось не дамо кинути наших героїв
Але чи мо можна так працювати якщо б
вони так працювали як працюємо ми і наш
Уряд країни